well I guess I'll be upholding my new
year's resolution to poke the bear so
here we are again and somewhat against
my better judgment I'm going to do
something of a follow-up to my toxic
fandom video from last year now in that
one my focus was primarily on where I
kind of considered the line to be you
know when mere disapproval or
disappointment in a piece of
entertainment turns into something truly
problematic so mainly I was talking
about the actions of fandoms I touched
on some of the reasoning behind those
actions but I wanted to do a little bit
more of that and drill into that some a
bit more closely here again I'm going to
attempt to handle this in broad strokes
and only cite specific examples if I
feel it's truly necessary or just
illustrates the point in a more succinct
fashion because last time as I expected
whatever specifics I did cite became
points of debate in the comics in the
comments rather while you know the
larger picture would go unaddressed and
I expect the same now I hope for better
I don't expect it now since that last
video I lightly taken a look at some of
the more passionate ends of a few
different fandoms and I do mean very
lightly but even a cursory view like the
one I took let me to notice something I
hadn't really properly taken on board
before
that's the linking of opinions to
beliefs by this what I mean is in the
realm of online fandom and punditry
an opinion is rarely taken at face value
as just that the opinion of an
individual instead there's frequently a
series of extrapolations about what the
person who holds that opinion is like
as an individual so speaking personally
over the years I've made more than a few
very nice comments about various Marvel
properties and not as many about DC once
and the extrapolation of that is that
I'm a Marvel fan boy who hates DC for
that reason and automatically love
absolutely everything the Marvel does
the possibility that most DC properties
of late simply haven't appealed to me on
a case-by-case basis isn't even
considered as an option and instances of
my not loving Marvel projects or
enjoying DC ones are needful II ignored
though it's it's probably just as likely
that those accusing me don't even look
for such things in the first place but
now that initial extrapolation honestly
it's not the most unfair assumption one
could make misguided and over simplistic
though it may be but the thing is it
doesn't stop there because Marvel is
owned by Disney that means I'm a Disney
shill with it who has absolutely no
problem with how much that company is
buying up and controlling when it comes
to intellectual property and I support
all presumed agendas of said company
because I like Marvel movies I mean
think about it this is not that far off
from saying you know I like cheddar
cheese and whoever you're talking to
then assumes that you therefore support
corporate farming and the Monsanto
Corporation who Breton who benefits from
it and you gleefully laugh at the plight
of a lactose-intolerant
we don't allow for simple tastes anymore
when it comes to entertainment it's no
longer allowable to approve of a movie
or show or comic book without also
approving of the business philosophy of
the parent company and those who even
tangentially benefit from it apparently
so
for an additional example there's what's
been going on Doctor Who fandom now I
continue to maintain that the extremists
on either side of the supposed fan
divide are actually in the minority but
I can't deny that I've certainly seen
t of this going on in that fandom so it
can't simply be taken as an honest
opinion or preference that one either
does or doesn't care for Jodie Whittaker
as the thirteenth doctor if you don't
like her or series 11 the most recent
one that aired then you're a misogynist
and probably a hashtag not my doctor
type who wants the show to be canceled
and rails against any expansion of
diversity in any medium or if you do
like her or series 11 you're an sjw Miss
Andrus shill for the BBC who only cares
about diversity quotas and cares nothing
about the quality of the actual things
product both of those extrapolations are
equally big leaps and i'm not gonna go
so far as to say that there aren't some
people out there who would actually fit
those full descriptions the problem is
the assumptions the full assumptions are
being made about anybody who expresses
that initial opinion of liking or not
liking Jodie Whittaker as the doctor and
evidence that the rest of it is also
true is not required and that is what
elevates the anger that comes into the
equation because if you actively hate
somebody for an opinion a mere matter of
taste well you're just being a jerk I
mean let people like what they like
what's your problem however it's far
more acceptable at present to hate
someone for their greater political
social or religious philosophies because
an opinion is just an opinion but
philosophies are tied to actions that
you may or find admirable or deplorable
and therefore philosophies are something
you are more comfortable taking a strong
stance for or against so all you have to
do is tie an opinion to a greater life
outlook that offends you and that clears
your head space to express extreme
responses over personal opinions let's
pause and ask the question how do we
even get here I'm not really sure I'm up
to the task of reverse engineering this
entire phenomenon but
well I can't tell you is when I first
noticed it I remember when Nintendo
launched the Wii in 2006 which was
basically around the time that I began
winding down my own active gaming a
combination of not enough free time and
not enough disposable income
now of course console wars were nothing
new I mean I was right there and the old
Sega versus Nintendo days but they there
was something a little different about
the launch and the subsequent mega
success of the week I watched as this
one console became inextricably tied to
its audience and I don't mean Nintendo
fans I mean more casual gamers the
concept of casual gaming wasn't exactly
brand-new in 2006 but I remember the
term being so loaded and filled with
derision prior to the we launch suddenly
a battle line was drawn and to own or
enjoy the Wii was to support a wave of
gaming that to many was simply
unacceptable so to them it wasn't enough
to just not buy a Wii because it wasn't
making the kind of games you liked oh no
you had to hate it
for what it represented and for daring
to cater to an audience that you had no
relation with or affinity for all of a
sudden you either casual playing Wii and
phone games with no interest or care for
the progress of the medium or deep
gameplay or overcoming difficult
challenges or you were hardcore you
shunned the motion controls you went all
in on the most violent most challenging
games available because it was the
opposite of what the Wii was doing no
middle ground anymore because a matter
of personal taste became tied to a
certain kind of audience oh wait Penn
Lord help you if you liked both casual
and hardcore games you better be
prepared to keep one of the
interests to yourself lest you be called
out and mocked for it I feel like this
way of viewing opinions has kind of
seeped into everything and people will
vocally support or denigrate something
not for its artistic merits but for what
they feel it represents so the problem
with Doctor Who isn't really Jodie
Whittaker it's the idea that casting her
was done to appeal to progressives who
weren't even watching the show before
and the problem with not liking Jodie
Whittaker isn't how well she does or
doesn't fit the part it's the idea that
not supporting the casting loves you in
with reactionaries who rail against any
change whatsoever in the worlds they
know it
you can't like something that's liked by
people you disagree with and you can't
dislike something that is approved but
the people you share affinity with thus
the echo chamber grows on all sides this
came up in the last video I did on toxic
fandom because I mentioned my own
enjoyment of the film 300 despite my
fundamental disagreement with many of
the philosophies that underscore the
characters and arguably the film as a
whole and unsurprisingly there were a
few folks who tried to take me to task
for that because if I don't agree with
fascist philosophies I have absolutely
no business expressing enjoyment for a
film that is believed to espouse those
same philosophies no matter how great I
feel the film actually is I really
noticed this undercurrent in videos the
kind you know the kinds they have titles
like why you should hate insert property
name here now these are the kinds of
things that I actively avoid because I
really can't I can't stand the starting
premise you know just so the title of
these things I mean there are plenty of
things I hate
and I'll rant about them sometimes but
what I do my focus I try very hard to
just be giving the reasons that I have
for loving or hating something not
giving reasons that anybody else should
or insisting that because of these
reasons other people should hate it as
well anyway what I actually try to watch
some of these videos in preparation for
doing this topic I noticed this very
thing that I'm talking about here that
the reasons why you should hate
something is because of the philosophies
of those who made it and the principles
of the audience it's meant to appeal to
be they real or imagined by the video
creator you should hate the new Doctor
Who because it's diversity casting for
its own sake you should hate the old
Shira because there was only one female
body type which reinforced unrealistic
beauty standards to impressionable young
people and it doesn't matter what the
quality of the finished product is or
whether or not you draw entertainment
from it these are the objective reasons
that you and anyone else should hate it
objective with the biggest pulsating
question marks possible around it
because it's become one of those words
that has been misused to the point of
blue of its just lost any proper meaning
now I'm not actually gonna say that
there's no value in taking stock in what
kind of people share your opinions
actually I think it's healthy every now
and then to kind of pause and
metaphorically you know look to your
left look to your right and sort of just
check the company you're keeping when
you go to the rally for the cause you've
taken up you know so to speak I know I
had to do that back when the
Ghostbusters reboot happened now I was
extremely better because I love the
original and could not see any reason
why this was a continuity reset instead
of a continuation and I just I really
hated that Sony was effectively saying
that's not Ghostbusters anymore this is
goes
Buster's but I found myself sharing my
negativity with people who were just
shouting girls campaign Ghostbusters and
frankly that made me uncomfortable I
think it helped my own headspace to take
stock of myself examine my own reasoning
for my feelings so that I could feel
confident that I wasn't coming from that
same place because I mean that opinion
never changed I still have it the new
Ghostbusters it was okay for the record
but there truly was no reason for it to
not have been a continuation so my
annoyance that that remains but that
sort of taking stock moment it also
prepared me for people who were still
gonna lock me in with the group that I'd
rather not be lumped with because I
looked around at some of the others in
this whole the reboot is a stupid idea
crowd and realized yeah I'm gonna need
to be prepared to explain why I'm over
here but to some people that won't
matter because nuance is a dwindling
resource and I also recognize that some
people will like in what I just
described as being like going to a white
nationalist rally while saying but I'm
not racist because the end result is
still support for that agenda but then
that circles back to my original point
doesn't it because opinions have become
agendas and you can't hold an opinion on
a piece of entertainment without
supporting one agenda or another you
will be judged for that agenda as the
anger towards a broader group or
movement or philosophy as a whole gets
funneled down and hurled at any
individual who enjoys a piece of media
that certain groups like or dislike
we've politicized entertainment and Wow
I would actually want to argue that all
art is inherently political no matter
what that's the kind of conversation
that used to only crop up in discussions
about the art itself
not in the likes or dislikes of the
audience I mean we've all heard the
cries that movies didn't use to be
political but they are now I don't think
we do that right I think we honestly
need to be pointing that finger right
back at ourselves because we have turned
our entertainment into politics way more
than the makers of our entertainment
habit and I do not exempt myself from
that to be clear I'm not sure if any of
this is reversible and Donner out a clue
how to go about it even if it is but
it's one of those things that I just I
try and keep straight my own head to not
judge too harshly on an entertainment
preference and more importantly to not
make sweeping assumptions about a person
based on a single opinion about a piece
of entertainment I have a friend it was
actually quite good at this I he will
watch anything with that Asner because
that Asner is a 9/11 truther night gives
my friend just a icky feeling about the
guys presence so he just won't see
things with Asner in them that's a
choice he's made and politics were part
of his calculation and making that
choice but he doesn't then assume that
anyone who liked Pixar's up in which
Asner played the lead is themselves a
9/11 truther me just extend the little
benefit of the doubt don't assume that
someone does or doesn't like something
for the worst possible reason there is
to like or dislike it unless of course
they themselves make it clear that that
is the reason that they like or dislike
it but dealing with that is a whole
other thing I think I've uh I've jab it
on enough for today so I'll wrap it up
there the shifting of opinions that all
opinions now carry political weight and
that we judge a piece of entertainment
by our belief about the audience it is
intended for thoughts on any of this
have I made any sense whatever your
thoughts are and as always I know this
can be a heated talking point but try
and be respectful please whatever your
thoughts may be drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it a whole
bunch of stuff down there as well
because there's buttons and there's
links including one to the patreon if
you feel like supporting me and content
like this in the future
a whole bunch of other links besides
that to check them out if you want to if
you don't that's okay because at the end
of the day folks you're the council I
just won the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]